The way we're going to deal with this is by pasting together the segments,
leaving out the J position. In particular, we're going to say that in order for
the output to be a permutation of the input,
in the case where, we don't have a match in the first position, okay? And
it better be the case that, the following two things are permutations of
each other. First thing in our permu, in, in our check is the tail of X.
That is we're going to leave off that first element. And then,
we want to compare that permutation wise with the results of
pasting together the first segment of Y with the last segment of Y.
So, we have left out the first element in X. And now,
we are going to leave out that same element in Y by pasting together the first,
remember, which J minus one elements, okay? Then from J plus one to N,
we're going to paste those together, leaving out the J position. And
we are going to ask the question, is the tale of X a permutation of that? Now we
know from our equality check, that in that J position, we matched the first one
of X. We've left that out. We've left out the one in the J position. And
we're now asking recursively the question about whether the remainder of
X matches is the permutation of those two segments pasted together.